nein sowas doch aller lustig zugänge
wieso wird nicht besprochen sondern
petrausch donau bvb schon alles klar
doch jetzt schon gesehen wahrscheinlich
auch schon den letzten stunden auf
youtube es gibt wieder so ein bisschen
bi von diesem fall ist justin involviert
also dass ihr kennt den urlaub davon
seit dem mega pablo und dazu gibt
tatsächlich paar interessante sache zu
sagen natürlich brauche ich auch klicks
um eine zehn kinder die ich mit meiner
russischen frauen zu ernähren
willst du mal ganz kurz in zehn sekunden
so was passiert ist für diesen
mitbekommen haben justin hat ein video
verhandelt wer das teil analyse gemacht
und hab dich da finde ich bei mir habe
lustig gemacht da waren schon ein paar
deftige lions dabei auf dem feld nicht
ob mir etwas von mir
euro aber es hat auch das sind ist
einfach so und ich feiern auch dafür
auf der anderen seite hat natürlich eine
antwort video gemacht mit zwei freunden
selbstverständlich und hat gesagt
schießen aufregt und das mega eskaliert
dein wesen gang longo als folge dessen
wieder zu den tough 8000 leicht und
16.000 display über die ganzen wg
partner verpuffung gekommen sind und die
kommentaren auch richtigkeit denn hatte
jaffé hatte schon so ein paar dinger
raus gehauen ja da hast du nun mal
gemacht wie robert byrd muss eine
lebensentscheidung nochmal überdenken
ich weiß auch dass mehr ist das nicht
verläuft zu um hier zu mir über denk
doch mal eure welt anfragen entlasten
ist einfach so drauflos einfach gerne
aber wir wollen heute das wissen
einzuordnen die videos zu wissen zu
analysieren und gucken wer jetzt wieder
steht so einfach super job gemacht hat
ist das ja wie in haft also ein richtig
richtig haften also deswegen ist wie
gemacht hat und seinen klamotten ganzen
faire chance sich zu beweisen
die objektiv zu bewerten das muss man
sagen ja ich glaube schon dass das thema
passe nicht mal ehrlich gesagt ich meine
ihr habt in der frage bestimmt ein paar
sachen mitbekommen dass die meist wird
kann man nicht mehr auf fragen wie
gefahr
der spricht daraus dass der ihn
vielleicht nicht so sehr mag
dementsprechend hat er auch seine
klamotten total verrückten und ich
wünsche mir wirklich schiffe abbekommen
außerdem so ein bisschen bei stehen weil
66 prozent ist leicht auf dem video ist
schon krass das erreichte zu enttäuschen
die freundin von justin gemacht hat er
hat über dieses ganze fashion dinge
lustig gemacht das mega party crashen
verkauft und als diesel 150 war dazu
würde ich jetzt sage ich mir selbst
nicht im fashion forscher sagen komm
lass einfach machen oder weil er sein
ding machen wenn es zu fashion nennen
möchte sondern machen wenn er bei hitler
nennen möchte dann kann es auch so
nennen anhalt schafften die tatsache
dass man mit der stop eine kooperation
macht mit seine seele verkaufen
gleichgesetzt das fand ich schon ein
bisschen krass war also ist das doch der
laden vom teufel persönlich geleitet war
aber in die die tränen kleine kinder in
klamotten das war schon ein bisschen
kraft und so merkt man deutlich dass wir
gewisse antipathie auf webseiten
vorliegt erteilt das wäre einfach die
person überhaupt nicht leiden kann
deswegen die klamotten umso mehr
interessiert auf der anderen seite hat
mir richtig krachte reaktion gezeigt
jetzt richtig eskaliert und es war ganz
interessant zu sehen dass dieses video
anders ist als die anderen nur häufig
werde gehärtet reaktion videos weil in
dem video kommt durch das mit der pablo
in letzter zeit hat sich zu verändern
sein konto bisschen umzustellen und die
neuesten videos bei ihm durchgehen kann
das durchaus auch passen jetzt aber
trotzdem halten noch ordentlich etwas
über diese klamotten aktion ab bekommt
eben weil alle anderen youtuber so im
kopf haben chemiker bis der zug der
somit mega kernser videos hoch gekommen
ist und irgendwie ultra grad falschen
text verwendet hat oder macht irgendwie
mal vor der kamera sitzt im text alle
möglichen youtuber löste damals dazu
gemacht dass weniger paare versucht sie
zu verändern ok und ja wirklich der
anstrengung unternimmt das ist dann
vielleicht nicht ganz fair ist dass er
immer noch so geschickt bekommt die
sache ist nämlich wenn man die ganze
zeit so viele helfer bekommt das fast
einfach auf dauerhafter ignoriert
niemand komplett so das kann mir keiner
erzählen ist merkt man einfach ich zum
beispiel heute morgen aus in die wäsche
gebracht und da war halt einfach die
tante der an der rezeption mega
unfreundlich und allein das hat mich
schon abgefragt dass dieser mensch zu
mir so unfreundlich war wenn man es
jetzt mal 10.000 vorstellen ist sie nur
im internet aber als 10.000 fach das
nervt schon es jedoch schon angespannt
deswegen kann ich verstehen dass leute
die richtigkeit gerettet werden darüber
muss ich sofort haben das ist auch was
er in seinem sack kommt lasst nicht
einfach in ruhe ich mache mein ding und
variabler und da würde ich noch in
gewissem umfang recht herzlich relativ
lange leicht verbreiten würde ich sagen
aber muss auch mal anerkennen der typ
ist acht seine macht gerade eine schule
der ist nebenbei noch selbstständig
machte sein ding das ist an sich schon
leistung bezahlt man sollte versuchen
wenn die personen hier sind krass
daneben nehmen die nicht die ganze zeit
einen weg zu werfen aber auf der einen
seite muss natürlich auch das
unterstützen weil ich es einfach feier
also ich feiere diese art von justin so
dieses mega provokante und einfach mal
gucken was passiert ist genau in dem
viel aber auch gesagt dass platz zehn
jahre mega arrogant sei und mega
abgehobene sich nur für den coolsten der
welt halte das muss ich sagen dass ich
glaube dass justin sich bewusst so eine
persönlichkeit aus dem fashion stelle
gibt justin ist würde ich mal vermuten
einfach dieses minecraft im hinterkopf
die alte mann ist mega kinderspiel so
ist ein bisschen unreifen seinen videos
und dann macht er auch einmal fashion
und er musste selbstverständlich auch
seine persönlichkeit verändern damit das
glaubhaft ist und ich glaube deswegen
gibt dass ich so in seinen videos
einfach weil diese session ding
glaubhaft sein soll so fashion youtube
michael wie cool sein wenn man so dem
bruch machen möchte von kindisch
minecraft spielen zu cooler fashion
youtuber da muss man sich einfach anders
und seinen videos geben muss man eben so
tun als wenn man ihn wieder braucht aber
so auch nichts anderes macht ja auch apa
red und ich glaube die kombination
daraus dass er in deutlich größeren die
fifa eingegriffen hat also irgendwie
vier oder fünfmal so viele abos dass er
hat diese fashion persönlichkeit hat und
dass er eben ja auch schon gut schießt
in diesem video kann man nicht anders
sagen ich würde mir nichts davon wenn
mich dann überweisen würden weil die
drei faktoren führen hat eine extrem
negativen resonanz und ich hab's gesehen
einerseits wegen und ja auch klar
youtube das video machen super aber wer
jetzt im gebiet zwischen abu raed im
kuchen tv ist mache ich dazu ja auch
kein video aber in dem fall patrizia
justin und da muss man muss man schon
den mund aufmacht auf jeden fall noch
mal darauf zurückzukommen ich finde
nicht dass man gemerkt dass mir so
richtig ja fast ein bisschen verzweifelt
weil in diesem video so nach dem motto
beiläufig versucht mich zu verändern ich
versuche irgendwas anderes zu machen und
ihr hätte mich immer noch an das totale
auf und machen nie fertig das ist in
meinen augen zu der große unterschied zu
allen anderen anlagen video zum halten
der youtuber sagt ich gesagt das ist so
zeigt das den in dem fall wasser
wirklich so das mega habe schon ein
bisschen verzweifelt oder frustriert
wird
denn für euch und dann gab es natürlich
auf beiden seiten wieder ordentlich
beleidigungen
neue spieler muss einfach leide und dann
möchte in der großen dieses mit dem
hafenfest also das schon komisch so gut
umsorgen aufrecht und mit rauschebart
nach einer lustigen diese gänge wird dir
was du siehst aus wie wild die
mexikanische währung und hier wird nicht
ausgesprochen sondern per auto
[Musik]
ein
bis so
bhp show deswegen ist meine
zusammenfasst ist support und raste mit
dem like um kommentare aber las vegas
auf der anderen seite so lange jetzt ist
die schweizer machten machen weil unter
jedem videos die 1000 touren sohn zu
lesen das ist einfach auch nicht geil